hey it's evan and today i'm doing a
review of a website from eric on youtube
and his website is i connect i connect
tools.com a little confusing but let's
go check it out i connect them tools but
there's no m in the website so already
i'm confused eric
we gotta have a simple process here so
the website is i connect e tools and the
brand is i connect m
so we want to make that a little easier
but anyway let's review the site and see
what's going on here
uh i'd start first of all with a logo
right this logo is is kind of brutal and
uh it invests even going to 99 designs
and getting some ideas to get a better
logo that that better represents your
company
he is selling these pens
and what i'm confused about here too is
his main picture has nothing to do with
his product so this is taking up massive
real estate especially if you're on a
small monitor and you come to this page
you have no idea what these guys are all
about so i would make the pen front and
center instead of making this chair and
the computer monitor here
lead with the product
tell me about
the experience so it says here it's a
five in one experience so
what is it that you do what are the five
things that it does i remember in an
email somewhere it says it's a pen and
it's a usb stick and something else but
that should be front and center you
should have the pen here the five things
and point to it to tell me what each
thing does so i can quickly get a sense
of what your company
is all about i'd love to see some
testimonials here i'd love to see people
who said that they used it they loved it
it's the best thing ever
if you've had any media put that on the
page too get rid of some of this stock
photography like i don't know what this
globe here is all about
you want to increase the the look right
you want people dropping a lot of money
on these pens they have to have a good
experience and it's got to look like a
great company that they're buying it
from
let's click a little bit more in so
that's the home let's click on about
so again we're using the same picture on
every page that's a ton of real estate
and with a picture that doesn't make any
sense it doesn't connect to the company
at all
this is the about oh we seem to have a
logo down here uh
again that's not a great looking logo it
doesn't represent your pen very well i'd
look to making that a little bit better
investing a little bit
on making that logo again pop and
represent your brand and and make me
want to be interested in your company
this is a boring about me page okay this
is a this is this is corporate boring
boring vision born mission
born motto we maximize excellent for
your success super boring tagline is
boring
you got to make me think you got to make
me connect to your business tell me like
who's behind this company eric where are
you i want to see eric i want to see why
eric started this company i want to see
pictures of him developing the pen i
want to know why he loves this thing
that's the story that's what i want to
get connected to what's eric's vision of
the world because this is boring people
don't like buying from companies they
want to see who's behind it so you got
to fix this page up put your face
and tell your story better
what's next let's go to the contact page
so again same picture again i'm not
seeing anything different on here i have
this stock picture of this woman i'm
sure she's not at your office show me
eric show me who's answering the phone
show me who's answering my email show me
something that's a little more personal
than
the stock photography picture if you
don't have an office that's fine that's
cool you're working from home that's a
great place to start but the way to look
professional isn't to put stock photos
on that people can't connect to
and last let me try to buy so maybe
place an order see what happens so
okay so now i get
i get connected to a new page for some
reason i should be able to have that
happen in the same window but it loads
up in a new window
here it's telling me in the title that
it's a four in one pen where on your on
your home page you're telling me it's a
five in one pen so so what is it i'm
getting confused and not having a great
experience here
again the design could be way better the
logo could be better the design of the
page could be better you don't have to
invest a ton of money to make that
happen but if you're doing it yourself
you probably want to work with a
designer or somebody on even 99 designs
or wordpress seems something to make
this look a little more professional you
want people to drop 25 bucks for a pen
right this is not a cheap pen this is
not a big pen that can have a crappy
design you need to have a premium design
because you're selling a premium pen
people are not going to spend that much
money
if it's not a great pen right so 35
bucks is the one that you're promoting
the one on the home page you only spend
35 on the pen
the pen itself looks actually pretty
cool but the website does not do its
service the logo the website the layout
the design everything is not giving me a
premium experience so there's no way i'm
going to come here and spend 35 bucks
the idea is neat it's interesting i
don't know how much value there is again
i don't still even know what the five
functions are and i've gone through
three or four pages of your site
so
it's time to remake this page focus on a
product let me know what each function
does show me how people are using it and
loving it upgrade the branding to make
it represent something i would want to
spend 35 on for a single pen
and tell me more about the history of
the company who's behind it why you
started this make me excited make me
feel something if you do all that
you're on your way to building a
successful company and driving more
sales online
believe
for those of you watching you like the
video let me know give it a thumbs up
below makes you want to do more and
please leave a comment underneath let me
know your thoughts about this product
you have a question for your business
leave it below i'll make a video
response thank you so much and i'll see
you soon